[Musik]
hey ihr lieben heute gibt es ein
außerplanmäßiges video ich weiß ihr
könnt das thema mittlerweile nicht mehr
hören aber das thema ist so präsent und
das betrifft uns alle daher ein
außerplanmäßiges corona überlebenstipps
video im bereich ernährung weil es ist
ja hier in back & koch kanal und gerade
wenn es ums kochen geht fragen mich
immer viele was soll ich jetzt machen
wenn ich keine frischen zutaten mehr zu
hause habe und wie in quarantäne sind
ich muss dazu sagen dass die behörden
sagen dass die einkaufs versorgung mehr
gegeben ist in deutschland aber trotzdem
bin ich der meinung man sollte jetzt
nicht für drei teile alle drei tage zum
supermarkt geben damit man andere nicht
ansteckt und damit man die älteren und
die nun sprache nicht gefährdet und
einfach mal zu hause bleiben was gibt es
schöneres jetzt einfach meinen eigenen
vier wänden bleiben jetzt zum beispiel
diese schränke letztens ausgemistet und
ich zeige euch jetzt aber mal so meinen
zehen tagesplan und ihr braucht keine
frischen zutaten das einzige was ihr an
frischen zutaten benötigt er sind
kartoffeln zwiebeln dann habe ich noch
irgendwas und knoblauch aber das sind
auch zutaten die sehr lange halten da
habe ich jetzt auch mit dabei sie halten
mir auch in der regel ziemlich lange und
ihr könnt das rezept mit den bayern ja
auch gerne am anfang machen und jetzt
starte ich einfach mal zehn tage corona
quarantäne was sollen wir essen am tag
eins habe ich mir überlegt macht ihr
euch ganz einfach spieler saniert da
könnt ihr ich hab das rezept natürlich
auch schon online ihr könnt dann einfach
zum beispiel statt sahne milch neben
haltbare milch haltbare seine in
tetrapacks und dann seid ihr eigentlich
ganz gut versorgt die schmeckt lecker
hält lange satt und spinat ist
eigentlich so ein allrounder der einfach
immer gut schmeckt antrag nochmals zwei
habe ich gedacht gibt es einen bunten
gemüseauflauf mit würstchen der ist
super interessant für kinder weil die
sehen dieses bunte dies in die würstchen
und wenn ihr kein käse zum überbacken
habt dann macht das ganz einfach um
überbacken geschmückt auch supergut
rezept wie gesagt verlinke ich euch auch
in die infobox kommen wir zum tag numero
drei türkischen linsensuppe das ist so
der allrounder wenn ihr einfach hunger
ab wenn ihr sie dort bleiben möchtet
wenn ihr zum beispiel keine möhren da
habt einfach weglassen wenn ihr kein
paprika markt da habt einfach nur
tomatenmark nehmen also es gibt viele
varianten und auch das rezept habe schon
vor längerer zeit völlig abgefilmt mein
tipp unbedingt zitronensaft da reingeben
ist auch noch mal gut fürs immunsystem
und linsensuppe gerne auch für zwei tage
vorbereiten also schon mal ein bisschen
mehr zu bereiten wir sind angekommen am
vierten tag da gibt es ja
gut das ist ein rezept das habe ich
gemacht da sind wir frisch in die
wohnung eingezogen erinnerst du dich
eines der ersten rezepte in dieser küche
weil wir hatten auch nichts im
kühlschrank genauso wie jetzt mann hatte
nichts frisches da wir im umzugsstress
ich habe ein ragout gemacht und dazu gab
es reis und es hat gehalten das war mega
lecker eine gute proteinquelle hält
sowieso immer mega lange satt also gerne
mal das rezept abchecken und nachmachen
die leute die einfach angst gemacht und
zu viel
deko
hamza 100 punkte genau es kann ja sein
dass er zu viele eier eingekauft hat
also unbedingt ein ragout mit reis
machen könnte auch mit nudeln machen
jetzt gibt es wieder in die türkische
ecke köpfte für die kräfte braucht man
eigentlich kaum frische zutaten wenn ihr
keine petersilie da hab einfach
weglassen wird der see lag ist er
mittlerweile auch tiefgekühlt und die
kräfte ist so nix und fester mix aus
mode also aus weizen habe ich hier und
das habe ich auch immer da und ihr könnt
es eigentlich ist man das ja auch wieder
mit zitrone mit ein bisschen granatapfel
zero und mit frischem blattsalat man
umhülltes im blattsalat falls ihr den
aber nicht da habt weil wir eben keine
frischen zutaten haben dann einfach
wegnehmen und in website rollen mega
lecker hält auch sehr sehr lange satt
tag 6 die woche ist fast überstanden
heute gibt totti auflauf superschnelles
rezept auch sehr beliebt bei kindern und
tortellini gibt es auch in der gekühlten
variante die finde ich leckerer wenn man
sie nicht gerade frisch macht oder die
gibt es natürlich auch in der
ungekühlten variante wenn ihr die
möglichkeit habt dann nimmt die aus dem
regal und da halten sie sich ja auch
über mehrere wochen tag normal siebert
es gibt gemüseauflauf einfach
tiefkühlgemüse nehmen haltbare milch
haltbare sahne wenn ihr wieder mal kein
käse habt einfach nicht überbacken
rezept ist wie immer in der infobox
verlinkt und jetzt mein all time
favourites thunfisch nudeln in elf
minuten zubereitet das ist wenn ihr mal
keine zeit hat weil ihr zuhause total
zugange seid ihr macht home office tiere
auf ihr denkt oh gott ich muss ja noch
kochen dann macht die elf minuten tun
für schule und haben sie das rezept
müssen wir unbedingt noch mal neu
abfilmen das rezept ist ein bisschen
älter
ja das machen wir sehen es nochmal neuen
typ und das passt mega zum thema weil
thunfisch in konserven habt ihr
eigentlich immer da also ich zumindest
und wenn ihr wie im rezept angegeben
kein creme fraiche habt oder frische 12
auf frische zutaten sind dann ganz
einfach passierte tomaten nehmen sehr
sehr lecker da könnt ihr dann auch
wieder mais ezb einzufügen und hab dann
richtig leckere nudeln mit ton
fischsauce so dass man jetzt acht
vorschläge auf meinem kammer die ich
schon online habe und gleichzeitig euch
noch zwei weitere allerdings kleine
disclaimer vorab ich weiß das war kein
super food keine mega gesunken rezepte
auch nicht ungesund klar aber ihr könnt
natürlich auch raich durch vollkornreis
ersetzen ihr könnt die nudeln mit linsen
nudeln ersetzen etc das aber eben das
was in den supermärkten jetzt am ehesten
weg ging und das was die meisten in der
vorratskammer haben gezeigt ein geniales
rezept und zwar machen wir kartoffel
gulasch richtig lecker auch schnell
zubereitet und wenig zutaten und die
habe ich hier schon teilweise bereit und
so habe ich hier frisch und kurkuma
irgendwann habe ich knoblauch und
kartoffeln die kartoffeln gebe ich jetzt
nicht so groß da rein sondern machst du
vorher klein dann sind die nämlich auch
schneller gar
[Musik]
jetzt geben wir einen beschichteten topf
zu aller erst etwas öl dünsten darin
dass knoblauch an anschließend auch noch
ingwer und kurkuma aber auch nur ganz
kurz auf mittlerer stufe danach gehen
wir tomatenmark hinzu auch schön an
größten dass die ganzen röstaromen
entstehen und anschließend kommen die
kartoffeln dazu und das ganze wird mit
gemüsebrühe abgelöscht so und danach
könnte das ganze wird es noch etwas mit
salz und pfeffer lassen das aufkochen
und dann braucht es auch mal acht
minuten mit geschlossenem deckel und
dann sind wir auch schon fertig das
ganze ist sehr dickflüssig deswegen
mache ich das jetzt 40 dünnflüssig
deswegen möchte ich das dickflüssige
haben und nehme hier ein bisschen mehr
verdiene das mit wasser und griff
wählen luxus sport ein luxusgut
wir haben auch nicht mehr so viel mehr
also einen das lohnt sich nicht jetzt
würde ich das dann gibt es noch mit rein
das ist einmal kurz einkochen 1 10
minuten und dann ist es fertig ihr könnt
das jetzt entweder so essen oder mit ein
bisschen bargeld mit ein bisschen brot
sehr lecker sehr sehr lecker auf jeden
fall
[Musik]
hier angekommen am tag nur zehn ihr habt
jetzt neuen rezeptideen von mir bekommen
die zehnte kommt jetzt und zwar machen
will cous cous cous cous ist mega lecker
und man kann das total aufwerten ich
ihnen gerne instant couscous da geht
innerhalb von drei minuten und ich habe
hier zuallererst mal kichererbsen und
grüne erbsen vorgekocht die sind beide
außer dose gewesen die normalen
kichererbsen wir brauchen ungefähr fünf
minuten und in der letzten minute gebe
ich noch die grünen erbsen rein und dann
ganz einfach abtropfen lassen so und
jetzt habe ich hier eine beschichtete
pfanne da habe ich etwas rapsöl rhein
gegeben und werde jetzt ein bisschen
knoblauch andünsten und gleichzeitig
auch noch ziele mit dazu und ganz
wichtig nur die mittlere stufe nehmen
damit auch nichts verbrennt also nur
andünsten
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich noch gucken mit dem wege
messer richtig schön feiern gehabt vor
sich bei ihr guckt man bekommt immer
gelbe hände könnt ihr auch handschuhe
zum beispiel tragen habe ich auch noch
ganz kurz angedünstet und dann schauen
was wasser mit dazu gegeben dass ganze
kocht jetzt da geben wir sie tiefer
erbsen und die grünen erbsen dazu und
jetzt ganz wichtig dem herd ausschalten
weil der instant couscous der guard
jetzt nur noch zwei minuten in der rest
sitze soll er hat ist jetzt aus den
couscous einmal mit dazu um den deckel
drauf geben und so zwei drei minuten
garen lassen
[Musik]
und dazu gibt es bei uns ganz einfach
rinder würstchen und wenn ihr jetzt noch
ein bisschen joghurt im kühlschrank
haben dann gibt das gerne noch mit dazu
das passt nämlich perfekt und ansonsten
waren dass meine zehn tipps die ihr
beherzigen könnt wenn ihr zb nichts mega
frisches nur im kühlschrank gehabt oder
einfach keinen plan hat das jetzt kochen
soll schreibt mir doch gerne in die
kommentare
wenn er jetzt noch weitere vorschläge
habt schreibt mir doch seitdem
quarantäne oder lebt ihr so wie immer
und geht ihr raus unter leute das rate
ich euch natürlich nicht ansonsten
können wir uns gerne auch weiter über
das thema austauschen oder
rezeptvorschläge weil wir sind wir jetzt
auch nur zu hause wir haben keine
termine draußen
kein rezeptur importieren ein da er tut
uns leid
ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch einen
wunderschönen tag macht euch nicht
verrückt bleibt gesund und bis zum
nächsten video chilis
[Musik]